That's sort of how to do
sampling efficiently.
The other thing is,
how often do you have to resample?
Well, in the algorithm that I showed
you, we resample all the time, and
that's sort of we have a whole bunch of
samples that are about uniform weight,
and we spread them out.
If I don't have too many samples
that have very large weights,
maybe I don't have to resample.
Maybe I could just reuse the weights
the same samples over again.
Right?
I'd still have to
apply the deterministic part, and
I have to apply the expansion part, but
I don't have to do that resampling.
And you can do that by just saying,
let me take a look at sort of
the variation in the weights.
I want them as uniform as possible.
And as long as they have a certain
amount of uniformity to them,
I won't resample.
So that reduces the number
of times you do resampling.
A second problem is
what if p of z given x.
What if your likelihood
is incredibly peaked.
Remember, you multiply the likelihood
times the weights of the samples.
If it's incredibly peaked,
that means that p of z given x
is zero almost everywhere else.
That's not very helpful,
because what that means is,
you've wiped out all of your your,
your possible predictions.
In general, you want to allow for
noise in your p of z given x.
Don't be so systematic about it.
And you also might want to
be better at sort of how you do your
your proposals to begin with, right?
So you want to make sure
that particle filter
sort of spreads out to
points where to begin with.
And one way of doing that actually
is if you think of a sample,
each sample you can think of as having
its own little mini Kalman filter.
So you can think of it as having a
Gaussian that sort of spreads itself out
and goes forward.
In general, you're much better off
overestimating noise and let your
measurements sort of narrow you down,
than underestimating noise and have
your measurements think that they're
much more accurate than they are.
Or I should say much more
constraining than they are.
Another issue is recovery from failure.
Suppose an object really
did disappear and reappear.
If I have no particles there, I don't
have any way of tracking it, ever.
So, a standard thing to do is
each iteration, you randomly put
out some particles everywhere, or
sort of uniformly distribute it.
Because if my measurements
suddenly have moved over here,
there'll be some particles over there,
and
eventually that will be
the distribution that will be tracked.
So those three issues of sort
of making sure you're smart and
efficient about your resampling.
Not letting your system think that
measurements are too precise, and making
sure you have enough noise so that you
don't kill off samples too quickly.
And this idea of having some
random samples distributed in a,
in a useful way, so you can track things
if things change very unexpectedly.
All these things are necessary
to make particle filtering work.